Voiceover: Everything
we've discussed so far
involved recognizing and tagging
or engulfing shady things that were found
outside of cells.
We've seen things like a B cell.
A B cell has its membrane
bound antibodies.
Maybe one of these might
recognize something shady
out in the outside of the cell
and of course this part over here
as we know they all
have a variable portion
right over here.
This is specific to this shady thing
then this will be engulfed
and then parts of it
will be attached to an MHC two complex.
Let me do that in a different color.
An MHC two complex and then
that will go to the surface,
that will go to the membrane of the cell
to present itself.
That's an MHC two complex.
It has little bit of the little piece
of this shady thing out here
we call this little shady piece,
this is an antigen presenting cell here.
We've seen as especially
if this is a B cell
then a helper T cell that it
also has a variable portion
that corresponds to this specific antigen.
This would be helper T
cell right over here.
This is a helper, T helper cell.
When it recognizes then
it will start dividing
into memory helper T cells
and effector helper T cells.
The effector helper T cells
essentially ring the alarm bells
and start kind of accelerating
the B cell replication
or I guess you could say
that the B cell activation.
The theory is that this is kind of a
double handshake process.
Once again this is what's
occurring outside of cells.
When we found stuff outside of cells,
we engulf them and then we presented them
on MHC two complexes.
Now you're probably thinking well,
I mean that's the outside of cells
but there's MHC two,
there's this helper T cells
but we've also referred
to cytotoxic T cells.
What do those do?
We've also, if there's MHC two,
there's probably an MHC one complex.
What does the MHC one complex do?
We can recognize shady things
that are happening outside of cells
but don't shady things
sometimes happen inside cells
and how does our immune
system respond to that?
Actually as you can
imagine all of those things
will be answered in
the rest of this video.
Let's think about what
happens when shady things
start to happen inside the cell.
For example it might not
even be due to a virus
or due to some type of bacteria
could be the cell itself is gone awry.
Let's say that this right
over here is a cancer cell.
It's had some mutations.
It's starting to multiply like crazy.
This is a cancer cell and a cancer cell
because it had mutations
are going to produce,
it's going to produce some weird proteins.
These cancer cells are going to produce
some weird proteins.
Every cell with a nucleus in your body
and that's pretty much every cell
except for red blood cells
has MHC one complexes.
The whole point of the MHC one complex
is to bind two shady
things that are produced
inside of the cell,
and then present them to the membrane.
Even a malfunctioning cancer cell
should be doing this.
This MHC one complex is bound
to this strange proteins
that are produced by the
mutations inside of the nucleus
and then it can present them.
You could imagine what the appropriate
immune response should be.
These cancer cells should be killed
and actually let me label this properly.
That was MHC two,
you're presenting an
antigen that was found,
those initially found outside of the cells
engulfing and taken out.
MHC one, it's binding to shady things
inside the cell and
then presenting it out.
This thing should be killed.
Now as you can imagine,
what's going to kill it?
Well that's where the cytotoxic T cell
comes into the picture.
The cytotoxic T cell is going to have,
that's a receptor right there.
It will have a variable
portion that's specific
to this type of an antigen
and so it will bind there.
Once it does that, it says, oh boy,
there's all this shady stuff here,
this shady proteins
that are being produce.
This cell and all the other ones like it
need to be killed.
The cytotoxic T cell
will begin to replicate
once again like other
types of immune cells
is going to replicate
into the memory cells
just in case this type of thing shows up
10 years in the future
and also the effector themselves.
This is memory and also effector cells,
effector cytotoxic T cells.
As we always know the
effector version is the thing
that actual does something,
it starts to actually affect things.
What it is going to affect,
it is going to start binding two things
that are presenting the same antigen
as part of their MR on top
of their MHC one complex.
This character right over here,
so it's presenting that same antigen
on this MHC one complex.
Remember, the variable
portions need to match up.
Let's say that this is an
effector cytotoxic T cell
and actually let me draw
in a little bit different.
Let me draw it like this.
This is effector cytotoxic T cell.
Its receptor, its variable portion
is the one that's
compatible with this antigen
that's being presented right over here.
Let me just label this again.
This is the MHC one complex.
This is an effector cytotoxic T cell.
We'll put the C there for cytotoxic
and what it does is
essentially kind of latches on
to the cell that needs to die
and it does it, not
only have this receptor
interfacing with the MHC one complex
but actually has a
whole series of proteins
and I'm not drawing this to scale really.
This would be much smaller or
relative to the scale cell.
It essentially latches on between the two
and I'm not going to go in detail
but essentially forms what
you can call an immuno synapse
which is kind of where the two things
are interacting with each other.
When it identifies this, it says,
okay, I need to kill this thing
or essentially I need to
make this thing kill itself.
It starts releasing
all of these molecules.
It can release molecules like perforins
so to release this preference
which will essentially cause gaps or holes
to form in the membrane of
the cell that needs to die
and it could release other
things like granzymes
that can go in and
essentially cause this thing
to kill itself.
The whole point of this
video is to appreciate
I guess what we haven't talked about yet.
We had already talked about what happens
when you identify shady
things outside of the cells
and then how you can kind of bring them in
and then present them and then
use that to further activate
the immune response.
Now we're talking about
identifying shady things
inside the cells.
Those get presented by MHC one complexes
and then the cytotoxic
T cells recognize them
and then force the cell
to kill themselves.
This wouldn't just be cancer cells,
this could also apply to a cell
that has already been affected by a virus.
For example a cell like this all ready,
so that's its nucleus.
It's already been infected by some virus
so the virus has hijacked the
cell's replication machinery
in order to replicate itself.
The proper immune response is hey look,
I'm a virus making machine.
I should kill myself.
It will wreck some of the antigens
that are being produced
inside by the viruses.
They're going to bind
to MHC one complexes.
Pieces of the virus are going
to bind to MHC one complexes
and then they're going to be presented
on the surface.
Let me do it this way,
presented on the surface.
This exact process can happen again.